yeah they have a ton of movies you can
rent on DVD and a huge catalog of
classic and contemporary films is it
expensive no also there's like a ton of
shows you can watch online I'll give you
my password my uncle my aunt my niece my
cousin my grandma and everyone uses my
account this is objectively cool hey
should I watch that new show no don't
they haven't announced season two yet oh
yeah I don't want to get hooked by
another canceled show can I use your
password I mean I would but like it's
technically my mom's account and like
there's a bunch of different people on
it my whole family is like they're
starting to limit the users on each
account so I I don't know I don't I
don't know
you're really not going to give me the
password no
Emperor Bezos just announced that we
don't have to leave our houses anyway
that's good because the outside air is
no longer breathable our society has
collapsed though we still see the chosen
one though they may be only a whisper on
the hum of our Collective dream a murmur
on the wave of our Collective law so the
point of this part of the skit is that
like in this dystopian future like we
aren't really worried about Netflix
really you know like there's other stuff
going on like really like I know Netflix
is getting worse like overall like for
sure but at this point I don't think the
characters will be talking about Netflix
because things will be like a lot worse
in general like I'm just trying to think
you know realistically about what's
what's going on at this point in in the
future so like the the characters in
this in this in the the story they're
they're not really talking about Netflix
anymore maybe they don't even know what
Netflix is so that's something to
consider
um I know there's it's like not the most
succinct way to like wrap up the skit
but I just thought like realistically
like you know
because like Netflix